real eyes real eyes Real Lies oh it's
saying so much and nothing at all at the
same time you should get that tatted on
your chest get that tatt on your eyes
yeah get it real
eyes every time you blink it
[Music]
changes welcome back to careful boys
we're afraid of everything check this
out what are some examples of cliches
that you like and what are cliches you
think are B yes oh the grass is always
greener on the other side you like or
hate I like it cuz it's
true what wait so you're saying like
everyone else's life is better than
yours no you know why cuz it teaches you
it's like The Grass Is Always Greener
what does that mean it means no matter
who you are you're always going to think
that the other person has it better than
you right what you're saying when you
realize no no no but when you realize
the truth behind it it's like oh it
doesn't matter who who side you're on
it's so it's just that's when your
perspective really changes this is too
Zen for me we have we have to move on
that's to
Zen but you asked I got I understand
it's just too too yeah cuz goes but what
is grass like I don't know what is
grass do you ever really touch grass if
you really think about it it's like what
the are you technically are you even
stepping on grass or you just hovering
that's a good cliche though yeah and
then now you can make your own grass
greener you know I think that one's
[__] dude yeah Grass Is Always
Greener is [__] dude you think you
think your grass is greener everyone
since Brown of course you don't think
that cuz you married your high school
sweetheart I'm saying G no I think
uh I think part of it is is that you
don't understand you you will always
think the grass is greener but you
probably don't have enough information
about that person's circumstances like
true circumstan yeah facts and you live
their life and you go I don't want this
life isn't that why is a cliche though
walk walk in a a day in a mile of
someone else's shoes walking a day in a
mile in our shoes let's change it to
that what cliches can we [__] up I like
that one I think that one is it means
more let's go around and butcher some
more cliches I could do it all day I
could this is my game fool me once shame
on me fool me twice shame on me Can't
Get Fooled
[Laughter]
Again so good fo me one shame on you fo
me twice that one you ain't G to fool me
again God damnn it the video of George
Bush at the podium trying to dodge shoes
this is one of the best videos of all
time I saw that recently and that made
me feel like the grass is green I still
to this day go back to watching
compilations of George W bush making all
these like speech fumbles it's the best
dude very relatable is it it is pretty
relatable it's really good it's really
good he's so human he's just like one of
us yeah just a war criminal yeah but but
other than that yeah what's another one
a cliche let me give you examples like
your cards right right it's an uphill
battle well this isn't a it's more like
a it's more like a quote right but um
and and a Greek philosopher said this
but you you suffer more than and you
suffer more in uh imagination than in
reality that's facts and I think that's
really true because like when you boil
it all down to like the moment it's
really just an internal emotional
reaction that you're having to the story
that you're saying yeah or the
perspective that you're seeing the the
thing at or you're fearing the future or
you're regretting the past and it's
never like and that's anxiety a't it
yeah yeah it's anxiety it's just like
you're not present you're not you're
just thinking about what might happen
and it hasn't happened yet I like that
one do you feel like the simple fix for
anxiety is just being able to like you
know not give a [__] maybe not that like
but actually like whatever identifying
exactly what you have anxiety about cuz
I feel like so many people are like I
have I have anxiety of social anxiety I
have anxiety over literally everything
right but then you find out what they're
doing and they're like oh I'm on these
meds I'm on these meds I'm on anti anti-
anxiety meds DN and I'm not here to
judge but part of me feels like judge
them is that is that the best way to
deal with you what I think I also think
anxiety is normal yeah like you're
supposed to have anxiety supposed
supposed to feel some zero anxiety
you're supposed to CU then you'll be a
psychopath but then but then when you
hear people take those anti- anxiety
meds they go like oh like they're
they're kind of numb to a lot of things
but that's I think those people have it
to a level where it's debilitating like
it their anxiety is so high that they
for for sure some people do but of me
feels like come on wa you you this guy
over here you're telling me you have
debilitating anxiety like not all cases
but can I push back with um having a
high school education yeah talk to me so
you might be the only person here with a
diploma there you go the boys in World
War II I think they had some anxiety
yeah I think they had a little bit of
anxiety when they they're storming the
beaches of
Normandy the guys in the boats they're
[__] vomiting and [__] I think they
had a little bit of anxiety but guess
what they weren't like and I can't get
out of bed today yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh-huh uh-huh they pushed
themselves up the [__] Hill R took
the beach [__] they watch TV and they
just dude you're channeling your
grandfather right now I know exactly
dude but you have a point though to an
extent when you if you push yourself you
can push through I believe that but but
I know there people out there but I I
can't do it okay fine but they don't
want to hear that though well that's
always what it is like I think at your
highest point of anxiety that's when
you're at the threshold to level up
really you know you know what I think
the the on a counter to that though is
they didn't have a point of reference
meaning like they didn't know what to
expect so they go I'm gonna be a good
soldier I'm going be a good boy for my
country you get the uniform on and then
it's D-Day and then boom boom boom boom
what the [__] all right I guess I got to
survive now that's true and that's
sometimes a little bit more easier than
watching so much content yeah you watch
so much content and then you're just
like holy [__] this is [__] crazy and
I don't want to go to War I really like
where you arrived that's such a hot take
but they do know it though cuz they go
through boot camp there's like a warm up
there's a work up well there's no point
of reference of how ugly war is right
that's what I'm trying to say it's like
it's like all of us do none of us want
to like we've seen so many movies we've
seen so many vets talk about how [__]
up it is and and then we know about PTSD
but back then the propaganda machine was
so good that we were so ignorant that
and all of us would have been like yeah
let's all go and then you had that
like we should all go yeah let's go and
you don't know until you're [__]
there and then some it's just like okay
well there's no Bridge we young too
right they were like 17 years old bro
when I watch Lone Survivor I'm like I
could do this [__] yeah hell no I could
do this [__] [__] fell down like four
flights of mountains and Sh half the
movie was falling down half the movie
just falling down I'm like bro cake I
know how to break fall dude human
Avalanche it's crazy at that elevation I
can do that [__] dude what you kidding
me come on bro that shit's crazy man but
like when I when I was competing in like
MMA and [__] and I was always think like
oh there's something wrong with me cuz I
feel nervous and I feel [__] anxious
and I feel like some type of way I feel
like there's something wrong with me but
in reality it's like no you're supposed
to [__] feel like until you listen to
the interviews of the greats yeah like
GSP Quinton jaon they're [__] balling
like they're literally like like
throwing up and vomiting and crying like
5 minutes before they stepped in the
cage like everyone experiences that and
then afterwards they're like glad it's
over I'm glad I did that you know what's
a big difference though it's like when
you see anxiety happen for people that
are in the middle of achieving really
respectable things or like doing big
stuff it feels a little more validated
but then there's also people with
anxiety that ain't doing [__] all day
yeah I think that's when you have to
really take a clinical look at why are
you feeling like this but I feel like
nowadays in our our age like I feel like
a lot of people are kind
of my Approach or my perspective is like
what life did you leave the that that
got you there though so I think most
people they have small amounts of
anxiety and then their anxiety tolerance
gets higher and higher and higher so
that they can get to a point where like
they're at the NBA finals and they can
like stomach that but if like getting a
parking ticket [__] makes you puke
it's like dude have you challenged
yourself at all in life I'm a bad
advocate for that because I I actually
do believe that validating anxiety just
leads to more of it that's what I think
you know what I think it is like I think
Society now lost like a mental compass
like cuz back then there's always a
somebody telling you oh yeah you know
here's a direction you should head hard
work uh strive for the best blah blah
blah but then if PE like kids grew up
without that no there's no compass for
them to head towards and then social
media is just like burying you with like
all these mental health awareness posts
and oh it's okay to be depressed it's
okay but then it's like now people have
an excuse to go oh I'm this way now so
so give me validation I think it's the
it's the swing of the other side so like
let's say our Boomer parents were
getting their ass beat like a
[__] right so then when they
maybe when when they're raising us we
get beat but not as bad as they did cuz
I hear their stories and I'm like you
guys got tortured we kind of got
tortured but not like you guys
right and then when we raise kids it's
probably going to be softer each
generation but is it softer or more
intelligent but also there's this this
other part too where like let's say um
like maybe Boomer guys or or or Gen X
guys they saw their parents work to
death so then they go oh I want a more
work life balance right and then the
kids of them are going to go what's my
passion what's my purpose to work and
then the kids of them are going to go I
don't want to work I'm a Potato yeah
it's like I it's like I it's justy but
then those people have all the anxiety
dude you know what it could be it's like
you're trying to heal from your trauma
and by doing that you're teaching your
kids this new way of living and behaving
with zero trauma but it's like that
causes its own negative effect I feel
like you need a little trauma bro
control trauma control struggle May
trauma is a wrong word it doesn't have
to be trauma that's a cliche too you
know the cliche of like hard times bring
strong I think that's true I mean like
trauma is is sometimes just unfortunate
events and it doesn't even have to be a
form of abuse like let's say you're
child and then like your parents got
into a car accident but they were loving
parents and then you you know you became
an orphan early in life and then that
can be traumatic right but then it's not
like yeah you've been [__] up and it
could have been prevented it just
happened and it can be a form of trauma
you're traumatized by the event but then
now what do you do after that and I
think there's not enough of a emphasis I
think the problem with the idea of
anxiety today is that it shouldn't
happen I think that's that's the school
of thought of people goes it shouldn't
happen that shouldn't exist in you that
means something's wrong and that's why
you have to medicate that's that school
of thought I don't agree with for me
like true I I I belong to the school
thought of anxiety exists it's a part of
the human experience and the way that
you overcome it is to actually face
it adapt you got to push and then you
can use a lot of different techniques
like meditation or maybe what type of
story are you telling in your own mind
that's the big one right you know like
whatever it is I also like uh like
owning your trauma rather than being
paralyzed by your trauma yeah cuz life
is going to happen shit's going to
happen no matter what and the worst
thing that has ever happened to you
there's probably going to be even more
worst things so you can keep getting
stepped down by it or you can find a way
to like use it to strengthen who you are
I agree with that and I think that maybe
we just respond better to that type of
coping style cuz like I'm like I I used
to think like oh there's probably one
best way to doing it but then I see
there's such a diverse group of people
that receives information so differently
that this soft [__] cannot
survive like this method you know what I
mean so I'm like oh maybe some people
they got to build up in a different way
yeah like they need to learn it this way
I don't know you know like have a
different Outlet pretty much yeah but we
do see like failed methods when you're
self-medicating like but every
successful person I always am able to
detect some sort of inner gangster in
them yeah you know like they might not
be like a [__] physical gangster but
they're like everyone has like this this
like spark or this Edge right even if
there's some [__] silicon geek like
Excel spreadsheet geek but you talk to
them enough of why they built their
company like oh [__] there's a [__]
gangster you find their drive it's there
yeah well I mean but they channeled it
into something positive yeah but that's
that's the exception right cuz if you
think about high performers that's a
small percentage of people a small
percentage percentage of people become
top athletes top entrepreneurs whatever
right so to make something that the
general public can kind of easily follow
and like be the best versions of
themselves I'm wondering what that
method would look like versus like to
raise the common denominator yeah yeah
yeah dude the the failure right like
that everyone who wins talks about how
many times they had they lost and how
they learn from it how they push through
it and there's so many people who lose
and then just give up and they go that's
a scam that's you can't you can't win in
that field you can't do it it's that
[__] so every time you hear Mark
Cuban you hear all these guys every time
they talk about anything entrepreneurial
they talk about failure so how do we
create I guess it it almost has to be a
consensus that everyone agrees that you
just have to try hard I mean that's so
so there's already cliches and like
quotes about failure where it's like if
every failure is a lesson or whatever
those are that's pretty much it but not
everybody believes that cuz cuzz you you
don't feel it like let's say uh you got
fired from your job you got dropped out
of school or whatever to you even though
it's a failure it it still hurts but
then other people are saying that that's
what you need to kind of grow from but I
think the best thing people can have is
an example close to them of a person
that they trust or care about that is
doing the thing that they should also do
that's the best thing you can ask
surround yourself with people who think
they yeah I agree cuz I mean like if
we're telling somebody they don't know
us they don't give a [__] they're like
whatever your solution doesn't pertain
to me yeah it has to be personal H did
any of you guys when you were growing up
ever have um did any of your dads show
anxiety at any point no not really
really yeah my dad's a [__] anxious
[__] he is a panicky guy like my
this is my like like I'm like oh dad you
know I'll meet you at Bali at [__] at
like 5:30 for dinner right uhuh I show
up um it'll be like 5:00 where are you
at where are you at I'm like we said
5:30 oh okay okay but and then like I go
to like B he's already like walking
outside like he's just like super
anxious like um things need to happen
now tomorrow you know so he's like my
whole life I remember him being like um
really like I'm like oh I'll do it
tomorrow and that trait never rubbed off
on you like you never started to act
like that I think I was like that but I
didn't like that in my dad so I Tred to
like opposite like go opposite I tried
to go opposite like I'll like I'll
punish myself I'm I really want to eat
that candy bar then I'll just wait wait
till tomorrow to eat just I get rid of
this feeling like I didn't like that
feeling of like something compelling me
to do something cuz I feel like I'm not
in control like something's pulling me
and I don't want to have something
selfcontrol right there cuz I'm like I'm
acting like my pops right now where I
[__] need something right now cuz
like that's interesting too like I've
never seen my dad be anxious for one
second but I wonder if there's a
difference generationally if bottle [__]
yeah for sure for sure but if we have a
generation now of men who are like
really outwardly anxious and showing
anxiety like what are their kids really
going to like yeah maybe they might be
like you're [__] lame dad I don't
maybe they might go the opposite way
they might swing back right I would say
the the flip side or the Dark Side of
being a tough dude is like I see it in
in you know some of my family members
that are like in their mid-50s they
don't know how to process and they don't
know how to like release that stress and
you see this in a lot of guys that were
like young Professionals in the 80s
right in the corporate culture back then
everyone was a [__] Workhorse and
then they were tough right they just
don't complain they just plow through
Workaholics and then like a lot of them
have health issues high blood pressure
they get heart attacks they get a lot of
crazy things and they don't know what's
going on with their bodies and I think
that's probably the the Dark Side of
just plowing through and not like
balancing yourself and maybe people see
that and go oh men need to you know say
they have anxiety and and try to deal
with it and I'm like yeah maybe May
that's what they're trying to kind of
figure out there yeah but it doesn't
work for every person cuz that's just
general advice given to everyone that
has their own specific demons that
they're going through yeah I think so I
think it depends on the person that's
hard cuz you can't do a blanket thing
and say like everybody needs this yeah
cuz like what if someone's already tough
as [__] maybe you got to tell him to
just chill out bro and then someone's
weak as [__] you're like okay you need
to like toughen up you yeah yeah for
sure well that's also that's why I think
cliches are stupid cuz it's such a
general thing and it can mean so many
things for so many people hey don't
judge a book by its cover tell that to a
woman walking at night
dude are you kidding me that's like the
dumbest [__] I've ever heard you know
what's a really good one realize realize
realize who says that dude that's not a
cliche that's a that's a PO it's a quote
right but that [__] is actually true
wait what does that mean that mean real
eyes real eyes Real Lies oh oh that's a
[__] it's saying so much and nothing
at all at the same time yeah it's just
saying like you should get that tatted
on your chest get that Ted on your eyes
yeah get real
eyes every time you blink it changes oh
[__] that's crazy oh my God you know
what I was thinking about the other day
cuz we're on the topic of like anxiety
and fear and stuff like that right I
actually believe a lot of religions are
created to try to satisfy that like
anxiety that we have trying to figure
out like it's the medicine we need to
know the meaning we need to have they
need to create reality and then they
need to create even if it's a false
sense they need to create something of
stability because the world is a scary
place so like humans come in needing
protection needing dependency for a long
time we have soft bodies and then as I
look at kids and and and I'm and I'm
just like kids are like vulnerable
little creatures and they're afraid of
[__] everything right and then when you
become an adult you actually don't have
any of that support so now you're in a
really scary place where one day some
guy can either kill you you can get into
a car accident some things can happen
and then now you need to like make sense
of like well if I die what's going to
happen afterwards or this whole fear and
anxiety do that how do I calm this down
and you have Buddhism and then it's like
so many different techniques to just
chill the [__] out cuz like when you
think of like praying or something like
that it's like it's an act of
mindfulness right to chill the [__] out
it's an act of being like this is what I
want this like my intentions in Life or
this is my intentions for like the next
couple days or putting energy into
something imagine being religious and
how many more cliches are into play
what's a religious cliche like uh like
God would never give me something to
deal with that I wasn't strong enough to
handle oh right but lowkey though you
hear that [__] that's a superpower bro I
think it does push you to do CRA could
be in like the shittiest situation
you're like dude God God Believes In Me
you'll find the light I lost all of my
houses but you gave me this test dude do
you think that's like a for do you think
do you think religion is like a form of
gaslighting your own mind honestly
that's what it is D I got to believe
this [__] or else you know how dare you
can gas and you need positive gas
lighting dude positive gas
lighting cuz honestly though if I got G
on my side brother if I got Allah on my
side you're [__] winning my favorite
thing though is like when I'm going
through a rumination session right and
my head is just like [__] going crazy
and I'm like [__] I think I'm stressed
out and I'm like wait a minute and I go
drink some water and I take a walk
around the block and I'm like of course
I've been in the room for 6 hours
straight staring at a screen I've been
dehydrated I was going [__] crazy
your body was telling you something yeah
it had nothing to do my mind was touch
grass the best touch grass that one I
believe when was the last time your guys
bare foot touch actual grass man don't
ask me no personal questions like that
here we go we got to go get a day a day
ago okay that's pretty good we'll go to
your retreat astr Turf does that count
yeah does plastic grass count cuz like
day it's right there I do it I do it at
the gym I got the turf you know what I
mean oh yeah and then I hold a crystal
you guys need to touch grass man you did
you charge your Crystal into the
Moonlight though yeah yeah yeah always
doesn't work do you do uh do you charge
your [__] that's oh the sun
charging the morning sun [__] charge
dude oh yeah I bet that feels nice y the
vitamin D that's good for your uh yeah
it's good for your morning routine hey
you'll be really proud I've been
drinking protein shakes but I do them
out in the sun I every morning make my
shake go outside freaking sunbathe and
drink protein wow dude good for you I
start off my day like that good for you
dog yeah that's a good
routine